German Chancellor Angela Merkel appeared to
be more than happy to promote her agenda in
the crowded hall in Davos.
"I think we should understand our national
interest in a way that we think about the
interests of others and from that create win-win
situations that are the precondition for multilateralism."
That was apparently aimed at politicians like
Donald Trump, who put the interests of their
own country first.
Japan's Prime Minister Shinzo Abe also made
it clear in Davos he remains committed to
open markets.
No growth without free trade.
Abe focused above all on digitization and
borderless data traffic.
The hustle and bustle in Davos is as international
as usual - but the atmosphere is more subdued.
Brexit, climate change, stronger nationalism.
Instead of the world improving, the future
seems increasingly uncertain.
The trade conflict between China and the USA
hasn't been resolved either.
And China is pleading for a reprieve.
"The U.S. and Chinese economies can't live
without each other.
That's already the reality.
So, the conclusion is that the relationship
must be mutually beneficial and win-win.
Cooperation serves the interests of both sides,
while confrontation harms them.
This is a basic principle."
Everything sounds reasonable.
Improve the world, treat each other fairly.
Everyone here agrees.
But: the world
outside
of
Davos looks different.